bro y'all keep your [ __ ] mouth closed
bro
for real how about koi [ __ ]
coy a real person bro when she real cool
as [ __ ] me and she don't disrespect
nobody she seems super nice i haven't
met her yet but real talk she had a
gangster you heard me
and she hit harder than the [ __ ]
she was punching me in my back [ __ ]
that [ __ ] was hurting low-key mm-hmm i
kept trying to move she's like no no
pack turning around
hitting me hard as hell she'll [ __ ] one
of y'all up
i better quit playing with koi like that
not for real bro for real she [ __ ]
all up coy is a very beautiful person
bro very nice very respectful [ __ ] her
mama showed up [ __ ] her mama real
loving like it was like a family right
there [ __ ] her team like they took over
the whole spot that was playing games
like bro they really i really really
love court like bro it's like this is
why i love wiz this is why i love
zack fox this is why i love like
so many so so many different people
because
bro they show up and they get a good
vibes i didn't been in the room with
other rappers i hadn't been around other
rappers in the [ __ ] and the vibes
trash trash for sure but yeah man shout
out to koi